foreign
born in 1943 who was one of nine boys
is it a coincidence when a mother bears
All Sons or all daughters
sometimes but we expect that to be rare
and
um
there is some evolutionary theory that
predicts under what conditions males or
females might be more likely to be born
the so-called Trevor's Willard
hypothesis
that suggests that because of the
greater variance in reproductive success
in males and this should hold across all
organisms although there has been some
research of this done anthropologically
in humans given the great greater
variance in reproductive success in
males than in females that parents in
better condition whatever that might
mean for the particular situation which
they find themselves in environment
culture it's time Etc
should be benefited by producing males
rather than females because a higher
quality male is more likely to outstrip
the mean repetitive success that he
would otherwise obtain whereas
um whereas females are almost guaranteed
to reproduce either way
uh reproduce either way and not at
extraordinary numbers so
um to put that in simpler terms a really
successful male might produce 30
Offspring in a lifetime and
evolutionarily really successful uh male
and a female really successful as she
may be is very unlikely to there's a
couple of exceptional cases but
um but so there are two parts to the
answer this question one the unusual
bias in sex ratio would be observed
sometimes without any selection at all
and you can calculate exactly how often
by random you ought to see somebody you
know who had five
boys or five girls in a row the trivers
Willard argument is that actually
the individual is in some position to
control what sex they produce and in
some position to know something about
the positioning in the world of The
Offspring that they will produce and
there may be an adjustment that changes
it from the random expectation but the
thing I would caution you about is that
even a random coin flip
will produce unusual sequences of heads
right unusual sequences of tales and if
you happen to catch an unusual sequence
it will feel like something must have
happened here why does that person have
all girls right sometimes it just
happens yeah sometimes it just happens
and you would if it didn't that would be
evidence of somebody tinkering to make
the world look more random than random
that would be your evidence of God right
there yeah yeah
[Music]
foreign